oh
[Music]
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now costs 11.99
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes mango aren't measures like
three boxes
that's it
eight or 11 bucks
[Music]
[Music]
bring my mango
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
don't raise
[Music]
[Music]
gather
[Music]
one for each night these shadows sweet
light to remind us of days long ago
one for each night they shed a sweet
light to remind us of days long ago
[Music]
you a treat
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
for the
land of the grace
[Applause]
[Music]
my
[Music]
wow what a performance on chanukah it is
the fourth night of chanukah
we are standing by for president joe
biden delivering remarks at the hanukkah
menorah lighting and that'll be in about
an hour we have plenty of time because
we are really going to be focusing in on
the interrogation of a trump rider named
danny rodriguez who has been
charged
in the trump riots now just as a
reminder for comparison
uh i don't know what joe biden is going
to do today from the standpoint of
hanukkah
but remember when donald trump did a
hanukkah party
he invited
the pastor who said jews are going to
hell do you guys remember this
[Music]
yeah this guy
[Music]
again i think part of the problem is
we're in this consumer mentality as a
church where we have the idea that our
job is to build as big of a church as we
possibly can and if we get into that
idea and fall into that trap then we say
well we can't say anything that's going
to offend people why if we preach that
homosexuality is an abomination to god
we better not preach that because that's
going to offend the gays or people who
know the people if we tell people what
the bible says that every other religion
in the world is wrong
islam is wrong it is a heresy from the
pit of hell mormonism is wrong it is a
heresy from the pit of hell yeah judaism
you know you can't be saved being a jew
oh that by the way guys that's code for
your jews are going to hell true i
believe president trump is the most
pro-faith president in history when you
look at what he has done for people of
all faiths
and i want to thank you all right anyway
it's all completely disgusting but so
trump's hanukkah
involved bringing a guy who said all
jews are going to hell we'll see what
happens today with joe biden's all right
everybody thank you very much
um
albix says via super chat some of those
clips in the music are old how old is
the pacman show it is um
16 years old oh my god that's insane the
show is 16 years old all right let's get
in i i just have so much to cover that
we have to get directly into it i want
to say thanks to ben ledwell or ben
ledwell for signing up via twitch prime
new member number one today kicking us
off i appreciate it a phone lines will
open if we get to a hundred and we are
by my calculation one out of a hundred
is literally one percent literally one
percent
i do have one person who is asking to be
unbanned on twitch
uh this is a user named random bullet
uh i will take out my
gavel
this is an individual who
showed up and said
how mad will you be when the white boys
walk again about the trial over the
killing of ahmad arbury
then
said
i tongue kiss my dad
then said i wonder how bicep guy is
doing think he od'd after the verdict
and the loss of a million dollar lawsuit
one million dollars were vaporized kind
of like his arm i think referring to
gage gross croits they were then banned
their unban request is hitler did
nothing wrong that one i won't even say
what the decision is you all know what
it is
very strange hair on my microphone
though it's weird
oh man
it's like cat hair i don't even have a
cat
um all right that's uh that's a perma
so uh that is that very very ugly stuff
very very ugly stuff
um okay
what else did i have here
oh joe biden was asked today
oh so listen i don't know how many of
you guys remember this but
way back when trump had coveted actually
let me even find the i i want to do this
thoroughly if i can
way back when trump had covid
and he was hospitalized we started to
wonder about the timing of the
announcement and when trump was actually
sick
why well number one
there was that story about how he
arrived to the debate too late to be
tested
but trust us he had a negative test
then the timing of it and then when his
doctor was asked when did trump last
test negative here's the answer he gave
i remember watching this with you guys a
year ago remember this when he had his
last negative test was it thursday was
it wednesday when do you remember when
he had his last negative
i don't want to go backwards
for people who are around him i
understand the contact tracing as i
understand it is being done
i'm not involved with that
so yeah okay so at that point many of
you who are very perceptive uh and
intuitive and me said trump clearly went
to the debate with kovid okay now we
know that he did mark meadows has
admitted it trump had coveted at the
debate um and joe biden was asked about
it today and here is how he handled the
question mark has written a book
revealing that president trump tested
positive for covet a few days before
your first debate do you think the
former president put you at risk
i don't think about the former president
oh man i don't know first of all the
fact that while he's being asked about
trump's covet he's coughing horribly and
the cough won't go away i am not missing
the irony of that
um but uh but i do like the this is the
the expression i just love it the former
president put you at risk
i don't think about the former president
i don't know why i love that so much but
i i very very much do
um
so there there is that
uh so i think that that's basically let
me check my youtube channel i think i
published a longer segment about this
yeah trump knew he had coveted during
biden debate yep so i mean at this point
i think we've said everything we need to
say about that and
we can we can move on i want to say
thanks to the hobo 1926 however for
making a twitch prime subscription
extremely extremely exciting stuff all
right should we should we just get into
it let's um let's get right in oh no no
i'm sorry i have one other really funny
thing sometimes people ask me like what
other stuff do i watch on youtube as
many of you know i very casually play
chess i'm terrible
um we have some friends in the streaming
community the botez sisters uh alex and
andrea
they are in dubai right now where there
is very high level chess being played
magnus carlson in a match against jan
napomnichi
and um today
andrea got into this press conference
that took place after i think it was
game five
and just asked how does the knight move
and magnus playing along beautifully i
don't know why i find this so funny
hello yawn and magnus um great game
today another draw who would have
guessed my name is andrea reporting from
botezz live magnus i bet you're really
tired of getting a lot of really
complicated chess questions but i've
been dying to ask you how does the
knights move
um that's that's a good good question
it generally moves
like an l and sometimes in blitz games
it can be very unpredictable thank you i
love that maurice ashley has this look
on his face like okay what that is the
question for real
uh
and i guess he's not part of the memes
it sounds like he's not part of the he's
not aware of the different memes so
we'll have to maybe speak to maurice
about that again the the
the knights can get very very complex
okay
sir did you see rogan suggesting
desantis gabbard 2024 oh my god
that can't be true
rogan desantis gabbard
that cannot be true
so for maybe if i search for tulsi
no
i was listening to rogan the other day
and they were talking about a republican
ballot with ron desantis and tulsi well
what's funny about that is
even rogan who loves tulsi isn't falling
for the idea that she's a democrat
that's actually pretty funny
rogan's just a right winger now right i
mean it's like i don't even know
i don't and it's i don't what are we
even doing you know
i don't know it's i i would be glad to
appear with him and chat about stuff
again
um i don't know i don't know
all right let's get into as we wait for
joe biden on chanukah
let's get into some meaty material here
judge amy berman jackson has ordered the
public release of danny rodriguez's fbi
interview in which he confesses to
electroshocking dc officer mike fanon
we're gonna go through this video
okay it is stunning absolutely stunning
stuff so what is what should we consider
in terms of this
this is one story one of the hundreds of
people
that has been charged in the
for their participation in the trump
riots this is just one
and it goes to brainwashing
radicalization
delusions it's sad in a lot of ways it's
it's a lot of different things so let's
let's just get into it and start
listening here's this first clip we're
going to go through this i believe in
the order that ryan reilly published
them um
okay here is where he confesses to
electroshocking the police officer okay
[Music]
what do you want me to tell you that i
taste them yes explain explain am i a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] yes why did you
taste them i don't know i'm a piece of
[ __ ]
i'm sorry i don't know
now there's a lot of speculate there's a
very interesting uh youtube video
called
this is very very interesting stuff
um someone is acting
there's a youtube video on
the jcs criminal psychology channel
called
what pretending to be crazy looks like
and this is a video i would encourage
people to watch
i have no idea whether the
emotional outbursts in these
uh interrogation videos
are genuine or not sometimes suspects
believe that pretending to be quote
crazy
helps them in their case
i if i i'm not going to play the whole
video but check out this video what
pretending to be crazy looks like a lot
of people wrote to me and said they
don't believe this behavior is genuine i
have no idea i have no idea i'm not i'm
just saying if you think that that might
be going on check out that video first
he's a human being with children
and he's he's he's not a bad guy he
sounds like he's just doing his job and
and he's i'm an [ __ ]
but why why why would you go up there
with the taser why would you take that
taser that was given to you from your
friends
and taste it it wasn't given to me by my
friends it was given to me by a stranger
i swear to god i swear to god these this
is not the same tasers
okay
let's go to clip number two the these
are really really interesting let's see
if these are in order that was at 8 39
a.m
this next bit
is at
okay that's not even this isn't even a
video okay let me go to the next one
we're going one by one here
okay
uh now this one was earlier okay so it's
not it's not exactly an order but i
think it'll still be quite revealing for
us
how do you get to
january 6 like how what's what else
happens in that period of time
tell me about that
how did he let you guys know to come to
dc so here he's saying trump told us to
come here
if he's the commander-in-chief and the
leader of our country
and he's calling for help
he thought he was calling for help
i thought he was
i thought we were doing the right thing
a lot of you wrote to me and said david
this guy is pretending this guy is
pretending and he's blaming trump
and acting confused and it's not real i
don't know that at all
i i genuinely don't know what to make of
this so we were just
i had no plans of what was gonna happen
i didn't know what was gonna happen i'm
not a leader of
any buddy
and uh
i just
i thought what was good intentions of
going and being involved in being a part
of and joining
whatever i didn't know was gonna happen
let's actually i think the better way to
do this would be i can just look at the
thread in reverse order
uh
let me see in the order one hour how did
he post these
okay we'll start here
um
all right let's let's start here with
this first one now we're going to
continue
look
we've done this for a long time we've
talked to like i told you we talked to a
lot of people
and a lot of people um
are worried about being judged when they
talk to law enforcement that we're going
to have an opinion
and i'm telling you right now
we don't we don't hold judgment over you
we want we could be the jury and the
judge
even even as
a fellow human being right
that's what we're telling you we're
looking at you today as a as a fellow
human as a fellow citizen of this
country as somebody who has lived here
and put an investment into this country
of your your work and your
you grew up here and
so this is rapport building common thing
in police interviewing look
i don't have any loyalty to any other
country such as america and this is all
i know and this is all i want
and i don't care about
any other part of the world except for
our team
so how how did the danny
that stood
on the line in between law enforcement
and antiqua blm how did you get get to
that point what happened in your life
like
how did you start going to these rallies
um
and just infowars so like alex infowars
stuff
yeah okay
yeah he's been around a long time i know
lots of people listen to alex jones alex
jones has some good information he's got
good information what the hell is this
guy talking about what good information
by the way small fuzzy moss did send me
my alex jones uh
impersonation globalist internationalist
trotskyite socialists unlike obama
trudeau macron
and the rest of these zio beasts
okay um
all right let's let's uh
let's continue here
you know i saw that that there's like
two sides to you you know there was this
side that
that uh kind of dc had
you know portrayed and showed you know
that this is your guy this is what he
did
but then i started looking in like i
said and i saw this danny who
stood in between this angry guy and a
law enforcement officer
just in a t-shirt
and his red hat
you know he wasn't the one with a gun
and a baton and handcuffs you didn't
have anything
and you stood in between to protect this
trained law enforcement officer
right
and you and just and even to say
something because like what what person
nowadays would even say something right
so many people just ignore look the
other way when they see
you know
like these wrongdoings right yeah but
you actually had the guts to say
something to that guy
and put yourself
you know in that position in that
uncomfortable position did you see the
day that they all came like 200 of them
and i stood in the street
yeah
you saw that
and and so
i think that's kind of what
what i'm trying to like understand
i don't know what happened either
is i want to know that danny though
i want to know
i want to know that danny that
you know that kind of intervened in that
situation and i want to know how that
danny got
to
january 6. so i i see people in the chat
who are feeling bad for this guy
and people in the chat who think this is
all an act that he's putting on
your story is an important story
i just think that
i don't want to seem crazy or like a
conspiracy theorist because you guys are
it's going to come out and i'm going to
get locked up because like i believe
this and it's going to put me in jail
okay
uh
so
uh let's let's continue
um there was uh i think it was hollywood
there were police there standing right
they were just maintaining the peace you
know
and um there was this
um antifa guy dressing all black
you know and he was just agitating him
and just kind of like
like as if he as if he wanted them
to do something yeah right like he was
insane so yeah he's making them look bad
so that the cops can do something and
then give you all film and the cops are
abusing you now and exactly exactly and
then i see you
like intervening
and you were like hey hey dude chill out
like
we're here just we're just we're we're
you know we're protesting like you need
to calm down it's not about that
it's not about you know
that violence and and uh
and that anger because he was he was
riled up
he was super riled up and you were like
you were pretty calm for the situation
you know
and and the officer was calm he you know
he didn't do anything i i was i was kind
of surprised at his restraint you know
um
but just just kind of seeing that
i'm not even sure what video you're
talking about was it with the wheelchair
guy
uh it wasn't that i don't know if it was
that same day you know the wheelchair
guys yeah i do i do i saw that one yeah
okay so the continued um
continued rapport building um he so the
police were they made a line in the
intersection
and um he goes to with his wheelchair
and he grows up to them and he has a
camera and he just starts like like
sticking it like this like all under
like the cop's face
and um
that's when i first started going to the
rallies that was still pretty new at
that time i didn't know anybody and uh
i i grabbed his wheelchair and i pulled
him back like six or eight feet uh-huh
and the cops saw me i did it right in
front of him
what are you doing you know yeah
and uh ever since then they've uh
you know because like
yeah i i'm a lot of people are saying
why are these people even participating
in this and yeah i mean listen i would
never do any of these things to begin
with
and if i ever ended up in a situation
like this
i don't think i would say a word i would
immediately just demand a lawyer and say
absolutely nothing you know they might
have video evidence of me they might not
any promises of leniency if i talk to
them can be lies
um
i would say literally i would say
nothing but a lot of these people don't
know that
they don't know that oh we've got a hype
train going on twitch we haven't had a
successful full hype train for a long
time i want to say thanks to fire
starting camper jay tandaway mason
windup cat and jp de beast already
exists putting us at seven also want to
let you know that you can use the coupon
code obama
to get a membership on my website
joinpakman.com
68
discount 69 percent is when it becomes
uh felonious so we keep it at 68 percent
and uh that's uh that's the way we do it
all right let's go into the
um
let's go into the next clip here
just like my colleague was saying here
you know
our goal today is just kind of to get
your get an understanding of what
happened right right um because dc kind
of has their version of what happened
and kind of how this is actually i mean
listen i'd if it were me i would say
nothing and get a lawyer
but the police are coming up with
exactly the type of story that often
gets people to talk which is listen
we've got all these different stories we
want the real story from you you're the
one who has the real story and then they
think oh well i should tell the real
story i see things
and now it's your opportunity to to let
us know you know what what really
happened right because
i i gotta be honest with you like they
they gave me this case right and
they were like this guy assaulted a
police officer
you know so
i was like okay you know let me look
into this see what we got here what's
going on just so you know prepared you
know for the interview and everything
um
and i i started like
finding these videos on youtube
um of these these guys post in uh armin
rez
um we are la
uh
uh
weber's way
you familiar with those
you know those guys those youtube videos
of all the the protests and rallies in
la right
and um
and i was like oh what's going on here
and i was like oh dang that's there's
danny you know there's there's dj
where'd you see me uh i think it was
there was one in huntington beach
there was another one in hollywood
um nobody saw me in an interview or just
in the background in an interview and
then and then at the protest right
they were at a back to blue rallies
and they were you know um
at these rallies that were like
for conservative values
you know american conservative values
they were like
you know and something about the mention
of conservative values makes them cry
makes that would make me cry too i mean
it's like there's nothing more pathetic
than that and at that point
at that point man like i was i was
thinking to myself because i thought i
had
an understanding of what was going on
right they said oh this guy's you know
assaulted a police officer but then
then i
okay
um
all right here the topic of lawyers
actually comes up
this is an opportunity here for
you to
let us know and help us understand
because right now we don't we don't
frankly understand
exactly what happened from your
perspective
and
i think that
there's an opportunity here for us to
get clarity on what what went down and
what you this is a i know there's people
saying this is this is david david this
is typical this is everything here is
typical in police interviewing i know it
is um everybody relax who when did i say
it's not typical
all i said is if it were me in such a
situation i would say nothing
i would say no that's all i'm saying i
understand it's typical this is the
classic we want your side of the story
we're just talking we want to get
clarity the clarity they want to get is
about the crimes you committed
right i mean let's let's be honest but
but i understand that this is all to
everybody relax okay everybody relax um
yeah the being handcuffed to the to the
sort of like handicap rail thing
that is an interesting touch that's for
that's for interesting now for those
saying he should ask if he's being
detained
when you're in the interview room
handcuffed to a rail
the answer is yes he could still ask it
certainly
but um yes i think at this point he is
being detained yeah that that's pretty
um that's pretty pretty secure now i
want to see now they're going to go into
reading uh his miranda rights and very
often again
i'm not passing judgment this is what
police do
there's very slick ways of introducing
them so like right now they're saying we
want to get your side of the story etc
if i were the police i would then slip
in now before we can do that before we
can get your side and clear this up
i do have to read this stuff to you and
you know you can get a lawyer you don't
have to talk to us okay you want to do
it with the idea that the real crux of
it is well we want that clarity and this
is just something to get out of the way
when the truth is again if it were me
the the the advice i've been given just
by lawyers i know say if you are ever in
this situation never say a word uh let's
see if that's the way it goes what you
see happen but if i do that i don't
think it's going to reduce my sentence
or something well
let us read you now he's not wrong right
he's saying i think if i give you
clarity it's not going to help me and he
may well be right because he did it he
did the thing some paperwork here
and then we can talk about
how you might be able to help yourself
out of your situation
and and remember the language is always
vague
we will talk about how you might be able
to help yourself any leniency that's
promised is not to be taken we'll tell
the judge that you cooperated okay
okay
i'm going to read this to you just
yeah let me know um
if you understand everything and then if
you have any questions
you know
um
you have the right to remain silent
anything you say can be used against you
in court the guy
i don't know if this is deliberate
but danny rodriguez is talking to the
guy in the green while the guy in the
black is reading some of this stuff i
don't know if that's deliberate or not
but he's being unchained as it's already
being read
you have the right to talk to a lawyer
for advice before we ask you any
questions
you have the right to have a lawyer with
you during questioning
if you cannot afford a lawyer one will
be appointed for you before any
questioning if you wish
if you decide to answer questions now
without a lawyer present you have the
right to stop answering at any time
okay
do you understand those rights
okay
you sign right here and you can read
them too to yourself as well
and just acknowledge that you understand
them
so now he's reading it
i want to talk to you guys and
in the past lawyers have always told me
you know you don't say anything
i'm not going to help you
well look by signing this
you're just acknowledging that you read
your rights and that you're willing to
talk to us at this time just because you
signed it doesn't mean any of these
rights go away these rights are always
with you throughout the entire process
that you're in the legal system okay
does that make sense
and and you have the right if if i ask a
question or something makes you
uncomfortable just to let me know
all right so he signs it all right
um
and then we now get into
very very substantive stuff oh before
before we move on i want to make sure i
keep up on thanking everybody thanks to
margot cabot as well as astro lycos
swoe loeb
and iri man
for the twitch prime subscriptions
putting us at 11. very much appreciate
that guys and over on the website
i do want to say thank you to carolyn
pugh
carolyn just signed up at
joinpackman.com and his new member
number 12. remember you can use that
coupon code obama
which saves you oodles of money oh i do
have a couple of other i'll just very
quickly mention i have a couple of other
new things on my sound board thanks to
small fuzzy moss i i mentioned already i
have the alex jones impersonation
globalished internationalist trotskyite
socialist shun like obama trudeau macron
and the rest of these zio beasts
i
i also have my beans rant from yesterday
you couldn't find black beans you
couldn't find pinto beans you couldn't
find kidney beans you couldn't find
cannellini beans you couldn't find
refried beans you couldn't find spicy
refried beans you couldn't find fava
beans okay i could go on all right and
then i have my pasta rant as well no
spaghetti no ziti no penne gnocchi no
pepper deli no rotini linguine angel
hair cavatapi tagliatelli fusilli
macaroni farfale conchiglier you
couldn't find lasagna noodles guys
okay all right so those are those are
now on the sound board and i think
they're very well complemented by uh
judge schroeder by the way how are the
calzones yeah
oop okay very good all right let's
continue with the interrogation i
apologize
um so just just so you know
my name is henry caramenta i'm a special
agent with the fbi
okay
my name is agent elias
that's the special agent this is all out
of order this is before
they actually mirandize him so so this
won't even be part of the trial
you seem to
have a pretty good idea while we're here
right
um
you know um
you need some tissue or something just
just let me know okay we can we can grab
you something nope no sense of crying i
can't be crying whatever i did
what's wrong with me
um so
what i wanted to do is kind of just
explain what's happening
um and then i want to give you an
opportunity to kind of
just kind of help us understand
you know what happened from from your
perspective okay
um i want to give you that opportunity
that's why we're here so let's continue
because um oh wait is this everything
oh no it's not
um
okay let's let's let's continue here
that that part is not even it's not even
gonna be part of the trial because it's
before they even mirandized them let's
move on to the next segment
and you think that's why you're here
today just because you climbed the
scaffolding
no you guys kind of told me
that i assaulted officers
like could we get a proper mic on this
guy
you want to talk about that
because i tell you what
everybody else is going to talk about
that yeah i'm pretty ashamed
he's ashamed
the the
like enrique said
there there's a story that's being
written about danny rodriguez
and right now dc
has told that story to the judge
now i guess the controversy here is some
are saying he shakes his head no when
asked if he wants to talk and then says
he's ashamed and there's now a question
i guess as to whether that's him
invoking his right to counsel and
therefore the entire confession gets
thrown out let's let's look at it again
i'm going to crank it up too
you want to talk about that
because i tell you what
everybody else is going to talk about
that yeah
i'm pretty ashamed
huh i mean it's a very subtle head shake
i don't i don't know about that i don't
know about that
if it's i can barely see it let me see
if we can even zoom in here i don't i
don't know that he's really
i think this is going to stand but let's
see
do you want to talk about that
he does okay he does shake his head
he does he does shake his head
let's look at it once more
you want to talk about that
i don't know if it all gets thrown out i
mean the argument i guess that they may
try to make is at that point he the
officers
broke the law by continuing to
question him i have a
i have a hard
time imagining
that that is going to be a valid basis
to throw it all out
i don't know
he's also not asking for a lawyer
right that's a that's a fair point as
well he's saying i don't want to any he
you could argue he says he doesn't want
to talk about that
uh listen i don't know we'll have to
wait and see because i tell you what
everybody else is going to talk about
that yeah i'm pretty ashamed
i mean
that
like enrique said
there there's a story that's being
written about danny rodriguez
and right now dc
has told that story to a judge
and the court of public opinion
has a story from the huffington post it
has a story from waterspider on twitter
from antifa and blm
right so that's that's pretty slick
they're like listen right now antifa and
black lives matter are writing the story
of what you did don't you want to write
the story of what you did you're telling
me what's the debating biggest story you
guys have probably seen more videos of
me i don't know all these videos
chad loader or desert border
all these guys they're all telling the
danny rodriguez story i haven't seen any
of those but
here's your opportunity guys please stop
telling me that what they're doing is
typical police interviewing i i know
that guys we're talking here can
everybody just relax like what
what is wrong with you guys
your story
my story is just that we thought that we
were
gonna save america
all right
um
ah so check this out
danny rodriguez's lawyers quote because
agents ignored mr rodriguez's invocation
and continued questioning him all
statements related to and addressing the
alleged assault must be suppressed
um
wow
let's see how they explain it
law enforcement must respect the
individual's wishes to cease
interrogation concerning any topic
covered by a limited invocation this
means no more questions not only about
the covered topic but also about any
topics that the police should know are
reasonably likely to elicit an
incriminating response
while an individual can reinitiate
interrogation on a topic he invoked the
right to silence on by bringing the
subject back up
the initiation must be done without
prompting here mr rodriguez
unambiguously and unequivocally invoked
his right to silence selectively and
specifically to any questions related to
the alleged assault of officer finony
for none because agents ignored
rodriguez's invocation and continued
questioning him all statements related
to and addressing the assault must be
suppressed
any argument that mr rodriguez reopened
questioning related to the alleged
assault by answering the questions after
invoking his right to remain silent
fails because all answers and
discussions were prompted by law
enforcement so
that's the argument i imagined they were
making
it is exactly the argument that they
were making so i mean we will see
um
we will see we already looked at that
pretty pretty closely
um
all right let's now they get into the
the part about actual the actual tasing
oh
thanks to tula for you and waleeda hc as
well as dirt nap and jam dog for the
twitch prime subscriptions if you're
just joining us we're looking at the
police interview some would call it an
interrogation of danny rodriguez one of
the hundreds of trump rioters this is
the guy who tased officer michael fanon
we're also standing by because in about
15 minutes joe biden is going to be
participating in the it's the festival
of lights my friends it is the menorah
lighting on the fourth night of hanukkah
and um that will be at the bottom of the
hour but in the meantime we're looking
at this interrogation video let's
continue
at that point he's struggling to be let
let go yeah and you chose to assault him
while he's struggling well i just felt
that like
i didn't know what they were gonna do to
him
and so you tasered him to protect him
and that
i mean that sounds stupid yeah
i don't know if i pray to chase him to
protect him but maybe just to like so he
wouldn't struggle and get hurt maybe
that's a very strange explanation
i tased him so he would stop struggling
and maybe hurt himself
wow
my guess is this kid's lawyer
is not going to go with that in court
that's probably not the defense to use
in court
he tased him for his own good uh it
disabled his struggling during which he
might have hurt himself
that it's almost what police might say
right when we have a police brutality
case it's almost the type of defense you
would listen we we believed that the
suspect was going to do something very
very dangerous and so to avoid the
suspect doing something for which we
would have had to shoot him we tasered
him even though it didn't really make
too much sense at the time yeah okay
let's continue
if they're going to beat him up or
injure him for like i don't know if
they're gonna what i don't know what was
it happened to him
and honestly i didn't think very much
about it because when i did it i was
like oh my god what did i just do and i
got out of there
i left i did it and i laughed
because
the taser that
was there was three tasers two
we
[Music]
danny you understand how serious this is
right
you understand that
you're the one
facing
like uh
full
full disclosure all the cars out on the
table uh you're looking at seven
what is that background noise
federal federal felony counts
i was just seven what is that the rest
of my life in prison
it's a lot of years man
so
if you're not completely honest with me
because you're not being honest with us
i am being honest listen listen i'm
being what am i not being honest i can't
help you
if you're not being honest with us
that's a classic police line
i might not be honest with you guys
let me play this week
okay he was looking up a video on the
phone i got it
uh okay i'm so stupid i thought i was
going to be awesome i thought i was a
good guy for doing this stuff tasing a
police officer all right danny did you
feel like you were
the three percent
here like like
like those people
that
stormed the capital that
those were patriots those are people who
are doing that because they were the
three percent that were going to
free our country from
fraudulent
politicians and schemes by the way this
is two hours into this evil people so
that way we could
have a
republic that was gonna be whole again
is that what you thought
you thought you were that three percent
guy
i know man
i know it's okay
i'm sorry guys no we we know look look
listen
we touch on the thigh
that's a classic police move
three percent guy i'm so sorry i didn't
know that
we're doing the wrong thing i thought we
were doing the [ __ ] right thing i
thought we were gonna be
i'm so stupid wait this guy's 38 years
old is that true
i thought this was like a kid
how old is this guy
he's 38 is that true
38 years old what on earth
oh my god he's 38 that's insane i
thought it was a little kid
oh that puts a new spin on it okay so
now i'm actually that changes my
perception of the entire thing almost i
thought this was like a barely 18 year
old
i thought i was going to be
awesome
i thought i was going to be awesome a 30
a 38 year old
so okay now i'm confused does the fact
that he's 38 and he's talking like this
make it more likely that this is fake
or more likely that he's a cultist i'm
not even sure i'm now i'm confused
i don't know
yeah this guy's older than me it's weird
um all right now they talk about a guy
with a swedish scarf i guess
let's continue
okay
who's that swedish scarf guy
that's who that's that guy
is that him yeah i don't know him though
you don't know his real name he doesn't
have a swedish accent
ah it's just a scarf i think that's why
they're calling him that
so you're looking for him too
uh somebody is not me
i mean
i just heard about it so i was just
scared you guys are just assigned to me
yeah they give us cases and we just
you know
he seems shocked that there's an entire
team just investigating him um here the
topic of
some people call it canine or q anon or
canoon
comes up and that's quite a topic oh
thanks to so 8500 for the twitch prime
sub i appreciate that guy
this by the way this is now three and a
half hours in is there really going to
be all these prison cells open for all
of us or what
are we talking about is there enough
room for all those 10 000 patriots
um
did you hear what he said there
is there enough room for our for these
ten thousand patriots like do they have
enough prison cells for ten thousand
patriots is there really gonna be all
these prison cells open for all of us or
what what are you talking about is there
enough room for all those 10 000
patriots
now it makes me think it is all an act
right i mean
if he still call if after three and a
half hours after the crying and
everything now i'm starting to think it
is it is an act that he's acting crazy
um
are you do you follow
very much
do you follow q anon very much is the
reaction that would be my reaction too
quite frankly
no because it's just uh
just right here one ten dollar bill
to one dollar
you were in the queue at some point um
not really um it was it was a
it was too
confusing and cloudy and disinformation
is it that genius
it wasn't that q anon is obviously false
it wasn't that the people associated
with q anon are absolutely disgusting
and out of their minds
the q a q anon was just too confusing
he couldn't figure out what q anon was
about and so he's like nah
he it sounds like he's kind of saying i
didn't really get it
um
man this is this is really something
else
this needs to be looked at like the
zapruder film
frame by frame to really understand
what's happening in this country
from the beginning
there was more there was multiple queues
so it couldn't
um
he couldn't identify the real queue
there were multiple yeah i don't know
what to make of it it's all very strange
but i do i i am familiar with some of
the topics of q
and like the um
the child the pedophile stuff yeah
because you mentioned something about
pedophiles uh earlier and so i was
wondering if you were into the queue
stuff with that well that stuff that
stuff's been out there for a while yeah
[Music]
yeah the pedogate thing um i was into
pedogate yeah yeah i was in
pedogate
i liked the first season but then it
kind of the writing kind of went
downhill i was i was i was following i
was
this that stuff um before
i
following
i need to make a copy of this name
thirsty yeah yeah we'll book it with
this property
man this is this is crazy
later on
i'm going to take it to toronto
well you certainly have your rights to
do that you can have a seat here we'll
be ready to go in a minute just don't
sit on your hands just try to sit on the
edge of the seat there i am
i guess i'll take my chances with the
jury
trial strategy he'll take his chances
with the jury
you see how they feel
well like i said that you are certainly
entitled to a jury trial and that you
are
more than welcome to talk with
yeah why would anyone do three and a
half hours of this without a lawyer you
guys are absolutely right
um
man it's all crazy
meanwhile a right-wing pundit who
appeared with tucker and megan kelly
previously called mike fanon a crisis
actor is now claiming that the maga
hide-hatted rioter who drove a stun gun
into fanon's neck was framed because he
protested it's it's crazy so that's the
gist of it guys we're standing by for
the menorah lighting it is the fourth
night of chanukah
um
and we're going to be looking at that
very very strongly strongly let me get
some of your thoughts on this i want to
hear from you guys oh thanks to jeff
waldorf for the raid welcome everybody
also thanks to dank snipper phil
ethel jeez for the twitch prime
subscription very much appreciate that
uh by the way guys please sign up on my
website we actually are oh i wanted to
do a thing where we were gonna do a
monthly count for the entire month i
didn't set it up yet but i should do
that i wanted to get an additional
counter so instead of day by day we can
have a month cumulative we'll count
everything from today but you can use
the coupon code
to sign up on my website that's obama
obama which was meme jacked
unfortunately by stephen kenneth destiny
bonnell ii
and uh molina destiny bonnell the third
okay chris asks where is his attorney i
know i know of course
i would never speak to officers for
three and a half hours about that
sir i don't know what to make out of it
i i don't either it's wild
are they all classic police moves they
are
he loki loves talking to cops about
going viral
thanks for all you do david i don't
think rittenhouse was fake crying on the
stand okay we're not talking about that
now
detectives playing him motivational
interviewing yep
omicron already in san francisco
is called the omnicron omnicron exactly
yeah i know it's been here for a while
there's no uh there's no question about
it the q anon shaman got 41 months risky
jury trial absolutely
absolutely very very dangerous okay
let's get to a few
um
voicemails jimmy from philly calling in
david
jimmy from philly white
so i'm still banned yeah what's crazy is
we are unable to unban anybody on
youtube because of a glitch that uh i
spoke to our youtube rep about it today
i've got three different people i'm
trying to unban and there's a glitch we
literally cannot unban anyone
so at this point if you're banned on
youtube you're basically perma-banned by
default uh because we we literally can't
unban
let's see what else we got here david
jimmy from philly what
you would sing like a canary in that
scenario david who are you kidding are
you nuts i would say nothing i would get
my lawyer
that's uh
that's bonkers david jimmy from philly
what
i'm guessing all that whining the twitch
worked huh
dear god very very aggressive is anybody
actually
covering
uh uh calling in about
the subject matter today let's see hi
david do you still have a 31 inch waist
as shown in your uh
e-how video for how to dress or get or
whatever that was about i do how to
flirt with uh an owner of a store yep if
you do have um
that small waist still what's your
secret is it just avoiding pork how come
you don't have a big fat beer gut yep
that's basically it
that's basically it it's just no pork
and uh
yeah that's uh
that's exactly right that is exactly
right uh let's see what else we've got
if anybody actually called in about this
hello this is whitaker marshall iii um
why do you keep saying this is actually
troy york like there's disinformation
from writing media is like any
information that you don't agree with
this disinformation no that's so you
have me confused with trump
trump is the one who calls any
information any reporting that is
adversarial to him he calls it fake news
okay
another call
if you think
only three people that die
from taking the vaccine
and you are the spreader of
disinformation this information
listen i'm aware of three cases of
myocarditis
that happened after vaccination not even
not immediately after
which may be related which ended in
death that's what i'm aware of uh
you know
people could send me other stuff if they
want
hey this is woody underwood and i just
want to say um i watched the video
and it's good to see a foreign-born
troll
such as the host of this youtube channel
controlled by what he saw on fox news
and i think that mr pacquiao got trolled
because
uh he's an undemocratic socialist who
man it's like what is troy york even
talking about it's really really weird
let's move on to something more let's
move on to something marginally less
crazy which is eric from mass hey david
eric from mass
doing the same thing over and over again
expecting a different result and not
getting it
that's the definition of insanity
booster
booster
booster
can they originally say
two shots
now it's
four five six a year
come on man
it's weird because we get the flu shot
ever well some of us get the flu shot
every year you get tetanus every 10
years it's just kind of weird to be like
the fact that there's more than one
vaccine dose
um very very strange but alas
people have problems here's the egg man
weighing in
hey dave
if you kill someone accidentally with a
gun
it's just negligence an accident right
you kill someone negligently with a car
it's a negligent homicide
even if you didn't intend to right
how come a gun is treated differently
than the car in that aspect tell them
wow the egg man with a very very strong
position there graham says many people
being interrogated by police aren't well
educated and don't think to ask for a
lawyer sadly the burden is on the
accused to request one yeah you know i i
am there's there's some people you know
there's all these youtube channels that
are like oh uh
um checkpoint refusal asserted my rights
and all this different stuff where they
basically look for situations where
police try to talk to you like they go
and stand outside a federal building for
hours taking pictures until someone
finally comes out
and then you escalate and then they call
the police and then you're like uh it's
legal i'm on the side where you know
whatever and then they're like i never
answer questions or whatever i don't
have this idea of like you know if i
called the police because something was
happening i would tell them why i called
them
uh i have no interest in being sort of
like unnecessarily
adversarial with police
but in any situation where police want
me to talk to them at the police station
at minimum you know other other
locations i would think about it
there's no reason i would talk there's
no way that it would help me if they
already suspect i've done something
by speaking to police without an
attorney
i might inadvertently
admit to some minor thing that i didn't
even know was a crime or there might be
some
to me minor inconsistency which
furthers their interest in talking to me
if i really didn't do the thing
um
i would want no conversation to maybe
accidentally say something
and if i did do whatever thing it is
they want to talk to me about
then i definitely wouldn't want to be
talking to them
but yes as graham is pointing out a lot
a lot of people aren't aren't aware of
that and it's not a flat like the police
are objectively bad thing
uh you know when we we've had situations
where uh
you know i've called police you witness
uh
a hit and run or whatever the case may
be anyway i want to say thanks to taba
lamoni for signing up via twitch prime
number 19. also a huge thank you to shan
chang
who just signed up on my website with
the coupon code obama
and his new member number 20 i would
love it if you signed up on my website
using that coupon code did you see your
clip with andrew yang on breaking no
what is breaking
[Music]
anybody know what that is my clip with
andrew yang on breaking
anybody know what that is
[Music]
breaking points
i don't know let's see
we'll look at that
oh yeah look at this oh interesting
so andrew yang okay okay hold on
let's mute this briefly let's check this
out
andrew yang joined youtuber david pakman
actually pretty interesting interview
all the way around that i recommend you
guys check out in its entirety it's
about 25 minutes long do it on double
speed it takes you even less than that
um but there was okay well let's do this
on double speed then why don't we it'll
take us half as long
no 1.5 his comments in particular that
caught a lot of people's attention on
twitter of course andrew is going
forward with the forward party he sort
of left the democratic party and his
focus primarily is on election reforms
so ranked choice voting and making sure
that you know people don't just have to
pick between the democratic party and
the republican party is kind of the
focus of what he's up to so pacman asked
him effectively well what would your
coalition be who are you looking to
appeal to and who are you willing to
work with on this project let's take a
listen to a little bit of that to make
it really specific if people on the
right say the republican party is too
centrist i'm an extreme white
supremacist or something like that but i
think we need to get you know we need
single transferable vote or whatever in
campaign you you you still welcome that
because you're on the same page on that
one issue
yeah if they're gonna help us transition
to a more effective democracy um but you
know i don't need to know what their
stance is on things that i disagree with
people have a sense of where i'm coming
from okay but right now i believe that
there is an existential threat to the
country um as a result of the greatest
design flaw in the history of the world
and if you want people wondering why
it's cut like this it's because they
pulled it from something we cut and then
they did a subsequent cut they could
have gotten the full video from our
youtube channel but they didn't help us
resolve that design flaw then we can
have a discussion about anything else
under the sun at a time when the
democracy actually will stand the test
of time
very obviously controversial answer very
provocative on twitter very provocative
answer and he goes on to explain like
listen you know he obviously thinks
these people are important and he thinks
they will he has confidence that they
will lose in the marketplace of ideas so
if they're partnering up for something
like ranked choice voting an open
primary something that would open the
way to a multi-party democracy they're
effectively signing their own political
irrelevance because they're gonna be
relegated to some like you know
extremist fringe party that's gonna
garner very little electoral support but
ultimately i mean there's kind of this
bigger and i really the interview is
very interesting as a bunch of
interesting questions that i think you
guys will find um insightful as well
about tech censorship and all sorts of
things but you know it gets to this
bigger instinct in recent american
politics where rather than expecting the
voters to judge the politicians the
politicians are being asked to like
judge the voters
and like cleanse their coalitions i
don't know about that i don't know about
this take anyone who might be outside
look if you're an extremist problem
white naturally that's obviously not an
edge case but also there's so much
shaming and calling if you don't use the
right language well see what's funny
about that is it misses the context
which at first i was like listen
half the republican party
does it believes trump won right so so
it's where does the coalition comes from
where does the coalition come from he
said anyone's welcome which made me say
okay well then like how about white
supremacists the idea that it's just me
trying to get i don't know if this is
what she's saying but the idea that it's
just me getting him to judge people it
was not the root of it it was
sort of like the the key question which
is
you need to find people who aren't happy
in their current political home and
let's think about who those people are
if you're not there on every single
issue then you're also supposed to be
pushed down in the circle and it's quite
antithetical to having any sort of
solidarity and having a coalition to
actually get things done yeah look i
mean i'm sure we'll get roasted before
too but that's how politics works he's
like look on this personal design
question anybody who wants to work with
me i'll take their vote after that in
this you know i mean frankly in the
system that yang is advocating for uh
these people would actually have less
power than they would in a partisan
message
well then you should have said that i
still think that it was a botched answer
because he could what he should have
said was i have a hard time imagining
any white supremacist would vote for me
not only because i'm asian but because
the system i'm describing is one in
which they would lose power
that's a great answer
the answer i mentioned yesterday would
be a great answer so
he still botched the answer influence it
within the party we have a small group
which is really dedicated i've talked a
lot here about naseem to livestream the
minority and or the dictatorship of the
small minority and then the idea that
they could then vote in a very partisan
primary setting the rules and the
preferences for the entire population i
mean under the rules that yang is
opposing that actually would be neutered
and it would make it so we'd have a less
extreme amount of politics in our actual
democratic design so yeah i mean so
listen again the the answer andrew
yankee to given would be
i am putting out what i want to do
and voters will evaluate it and decide
what to do i'm not checking
anyone's creds on any issue
if they want to support what i do but
what i can tell you from experience and
from identity and from the fact that
they would lose power white supremacists
aren't going to want to support what i'm
doing right that's that's a perfect
answer
but he didn't give that answer he said
yeah they're welcome you do care about
silencing or at least you know trying to
modify or stop the influence of people
who have appointed views this would
probably be the best way in order to get
that done but of course nobody thinks
about it from an actual policy and
practical point of view and yang to his
credit what i really like about this
current iteration of andrew yang is
after losing the you know the new york
primary he seems to be returning to what
made him him in the first place and i
think what saying he'd what what
what made him him in the first place was
ubi having that honesty having and
really the willingness to have a
conversation with anybody under the sun
which i think is very important um he is
being pressed and asked questions which
you would never hear from the corporate
media and then answering them i think
truthfully to his actual state of aim so
i very much welcome you know his current
iteration i think was very brave of him
to say so despite the fact that he's
gonna get attacked for it i think it's
exactly the right attitude that you have
to have he seems to be saying it was a
great it was great for andrew yang to
admit he would he would welcome the
white supremacist that seems like a
really bad idea actually even even yang
said it was a mistake being really
serious about what you want to get done
yeah and having them as like they're
voting for this in some valid initiative
or whatever is different than having
people with you know important views or
helping to drive the direction of
whatever you're doing etc like that's
obviously a very different scenario
there's also something very interesting
that happens when pac-man asks him this
question which is that you actually see
andrew sit for a second and think before
responding which is like
it's amazing how unusual it is for
people to actually be sort of grappling
with something in real time and not just
spew out whatever talking points or
cover story they think you ultimately
want to hear now as you know for me the
jury is a little bit more still out on
the new project on whether it's going to
be effective all right interesting clip
but yeah i don't think they're being i
don't think they're attacking me uh i
mean yeah he thought about it but he
came up with a kind of a strange answer
um yang tweeted a shout out to brett
weinstein yeah brett weinstein okay i'll
talk tell you about it after imhof
oh good uh doug emhoff is actually
jewish so it makes sense he would be he
would be part of this it is the fourth
night of chanukah here we go
[Applause]
powerful moment
thanks domis for the twitch sub
thank you please be seated please
thank you
well
welcome to the white house
whether you are with us in person or
joining us from your own home we are so
grateful to share the traditions of this
special holiday with all of you
hanukkah usually comes in the final
weeks of the year when the light of the
day is cut short by long nights
surrounded by the cold shadow of winter
we remember another time i see people
saying i should post a picture i'll i'll
light my menorah after this and i will
post the picture to my instagram i will
do that burned for eight impossible
nights
the story of the maccabees is as
timeless today as it was 2 000 years ago
a story of finding the courage to stand
up for what's right even when the odds
are against us
a faith that finds the foundations of
our future in the wreckage of our past
and a and of a hope that spreads from
the heart like the flame of a shamash
right tonight on this fourth night of
hanukkah we see the miracle of life
both on our candles and in our
communities
the nurses who work through the night
to keep us healthy
the educators who helped carry our
students through one of the hardest
times in memory
the military families who bear the
weight of our national
security the friends who help us
in our time of need
the children who inspire us
to build a better future
with courage and compassion with love
and grace with small acts of kindness
we are a light
to one another
we shine through the darkness
of a broken world right
and now
it is my honor to introduce someone who
is a light in so many lives
he's a loving father
and husband
educator and friend
please welcome the second gentleman of
the united states doug emer
[Applause]
the relevance here guys is that doug
amhof is jewish so because it's hanukkah
he will be making a statement of some
kind here
thank you jill
for being such a light in all of our
lives let's hear it for our first lady
[Applause]
and
and this light is exemplified by the
beauty of the beautiful direct
decorations we see all around us here in
the white house you did such an amazing
job thank you
you know a few weeks ago
i visited my childhood home in old
bridge new jersey
and thank you two people clapping you
gotta like that and what an experience
so i actually got to peer into the house
and i saw the windowsill
where our family menorah sat
i went back to my temple where i was bar
mitzvahed unannounced
and that was in a brown three-piece
floor suit mind you
um and then to think that today
i'm here before you as the first jewish
spouse of an american president or vice
president celebrating hanukkah
in the people's house
[Music]
big energy today
it's it's humbling and it's not lost on
me that i stand before you all on behalf
of all the jewish families and
communities out there across our country
i understand that and i really
appreciate it and as our great president
has said
our history our values as jews are an
essential part of who we are as
americans
jewish values are american values and i
believe this deeply
[Applause]
and that's really what makes us being
here together just together so powerful
so
i'd like uh to take a moment to
acknowledge my friend hanan weissman who
is the uh
and on is the white house liaison to the
jewish community
who's not only helped plan this but a
beautiful event but it's helped me so
much to be able to to communicate the
things i want to communicate to our
community and and the in the country and
the world and this week kanan and his
wife alana welcomed their new baby rosie
to the world so
[Applause]
so tonight we are celebrating
hananuka
sorry
yeah good it's true okay in addition to
hanukkah
and now i get to do one of my favorite
things as second gentleman introduce the
vice president
she loves her country she loves her
family and she loves celebrating
hanukkah which we honored together
earlier this week when she and i lit the
first candle on the first menorah ever
in the vice president's residence so we
were proud and honored to do that ladies
and gentlemen my wife the vice president
wow
[Applause]
oh man
and i love my husband
happy hanukkah everyone happy hanukkah
to our great phenomenal president joe
biden to our phenomenal first lady jill
biden thank you for welcoming all of us
and for what you do every day for what
you do every day
um majority leader chuck schumer
thank you for your leadership
and rabbi lauren holtz blood and rabbi
dr aaron glatt and all the rabbis
here tonight thank you
for joining us and always lifting our
spirits
and reminding us of the importance
of seeing the light in each other
and through
these periods that we experience
of darkness always reminding us
of what each of us has and can give to
each other that is about light
it is an honor to be here with friends
old and new
and to mark the fourth night of hanukkah
as the second gentleman the first second
gentleman said
hanukkah is one of our fam family
favorites as a holiday and every year
our family like so many around the world
gather to reflect on the lessons of the
hanukkah story
the power of the people
the possibility of the future
that even in despair
there is hope
that even in darkness there is light
we all know for 2 000 years
these important lessons have been a
beacon for people around our world as
jews have gathered to light the menorah
a tradition that has endured
yes during moments of darkness
a tradition that has endured
in moments also of celebration
we have
known and always known that we will not
be deterred
that we will not be distracted
from what we know is good
and our commitment and an enduring
commitment to good after world war ii
we remember jewish immigrants together
with merchants and members of the coast
guard gathered for hanukkah services on
ellis island and as doug mentioned he
went to ellis island and and looked at
the papers of his
family members who arrived in the united
states through elvis island
decades later when a brick was thrown
through the window of a jewish home in
billings montana the town came together
thousands put menorahs in their windows
in a stand against hate
and just last year
as hospitals and nursing homes
staff members celebrated hanukkah with
patients who were separated from their
families due to the pandemic
so tonight we carry on this ancient
tradition
this sacred
tradition
and when we light this beautiful menorah
we will do so
not only for ourselves
but for all those who came before
and for all those who have yet to arrive
as one candle lights many
may the hope we share tonight
ignite the hope
throughout our world for generations to
come
and now it is my honor to introduce a
man of deep faith
i work with him every day
and he is guided by the light always
a leader who deeply understands the
jewish faith
and stands with the jewish people
of our nation and our world
our president joe biden
let's hope there's no uh off-color
jewish jokes here from biden a very very
nice guy but gaff prone as many of you
know
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
thank you thank you
thank you
please thank you
[Applause]
my name is joe biden i am jill's husband
joe blyden
washington and many other places it's
already brilliant happy hanukk everyone
you know
first i want to thank uh uh doug and
kamala
and this is a white house tradition the
white house tradition
but the first time in history it is a
family tradition
doug we're honored that you are you're
leading the menorah lady
and i i see my dear friends and from
congress and the community out there
many of whom i've known for a long long
time
and i know
how many more are joining us virtually
you know
first of all i want to welcome our
cabinet members
attorney general merrick garland stand
up so i didn't see
[Applause]
[Music]
he is practicing the jewish tradition
restoring justice to the justice
department
that's actually kind of clever i have to
say
[Applause]
that i like
the secretary of homeland security allie
marcus who has maybe one of the toughest
jobs in government one of the
the widest breadth and i want to thank
you ali for all you do thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
by the way the anti-semites are molding
right now
head of ostp
director eric lander eric
[Applause]
and i want to welcome israel's newest
ambassador to the united states michael
herzog michael
please stand up come on stand up
[Music]
ambassador i look forward to working
with you
to reaffirm the long-standing ties
between the united states and the state
of israel
i was saying to a couple of younger
members of my staff before i came over
but the many times i've been to israel i
said not all of a sudden i realized god
you're getting old
i have known every
every prime minister well
since golda meir including gold in my
ear
and
during the six day war i had an
opportunity to
she invited me to come over because i
was going to be the liaison between she
and the egyptians about the suez and so
on and so forth
and i sat in front of her desk
chuck and she had a guy her staff member
to my right his name was rabin
and she kept flipping those maps up and
down she had that bibi of maps and kept
and it was it was so he's referring to
yitzhak rabin who who was of course
assassinated
all of a sudden she looked at me and she
said mr ambassador would you like a
photograph
and i thought
okay
we got up we walked out the three of us
are standing in that that rectangular
area outside the office
and uh
we the photographers are taking pictures
in the press
and chuck without turning her head she
looks straight ahead but talking to me
she said
why she said why do you look so sad
and i said i almost turned and i said
well madam prime minister i said you've
painted such a dismal picture she said
oh no no no she said don't worry he said
we have a secret weapon
in our battle in this area
and i almost turned again i said what's
that she said we have no place else to
go
ladies and gentlemen
you know uh
as doug
leads our candle lighting
he'll be joined by leader schumer
a good friend of mine chuck uh we're so
sorry about your dad
abe
was uh passed away
and chuck uh
you said in the eulogy of your dad if
you don't mind my saying this
you said he never quit he never cut
corners
he led by example
he knew we had responsibility to others
beyond ourselves and he lived with the
conviction that doing the right thing
even when it doesn't when others don't
will lead to success
chuck he described you
he described you pal
and on you could use the same words to
describe you
and you know
in abe's blessed memory i hope
you continue to lead us thank you thank
you
we also have a dear friend of mine for
more than three decades someone many of
you know as a devoted leader uh
community leader uh
um susie stern susie thank you for all
you've done
it is shocking not to bring an
anti-semitic pastor to a hanukkah thing
after trump i figured there must be one
somewhere in there rabbi dr glatt has
been the champion of encouraging his uh
congregants and his community to get
vaccinated
and i also love
rabbi doctor glass description of
hanukkah he said and i quote a jewish
holiday is uh as hanukkah rabbi
the jewish holiday of hanukkah is
thanksgiving on steroids
thanksgiving on steroids well that's
pretty good from rabbi
dr glatt and uh theologica theological
and medical opinion merged into one
rabbi that's interesting look
more seriously uh
rabbis described america as a great
nation of kindness
and that's what we must always be
a great nation of kindness that's not
hyperbole that's a fact
you know we're the most unique nation in
the world we're the only nations it's
not based on ethnicity or religion right
it's we're based on an idea
an idea
we hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men and women are created equal
and doubt about it it's an idea
and so that's why and our basis of our
strength
is not the example of our power but the
power of our example right and each
successive generation
the hanukkah story provides a powerful
lesson and nourishes the wellspring of
hope
in darkness there's light and cynicism
there's hope and optimism and an
unyielding belief
that miracles are are possible
when i was recently as chuck knows when
i was recently with talking with xi
jinping he reminded me said i know i
know i know as you said want to ask you
to define america he said i can do it in
one word
possibilities
possibilities
that's who we are a nation of
possibilities
and one such miracle
brings us to a menorah we're lighting
tonight
the artists who designed it
as manfred
manfred anson
was one of 20 boys selected by the
jewish welfare society to flee germany
from austria in the beginning of world
war ii
a miracle but one shadow by darkness as
his younger brother didn't make it out
killed in the concentration camp
pain the pain
is easy in the pain it's easy to lose
hope and harden what's left of a broken
heart and a broken soul
but not anson
he joined the australian army
and fought against the fascists
after the war his sister who survived
the concentration camps wrote a letter
addressed simply to
manford anson australia
that was all it said
it was a miracle the letter found him
it found him
they reunited
their parents
had survived the war but had not lived
long enough to see their surviving son
manford and his sister came to the
united states and in gratitude opted
a a it was a adopted homeland he began
collecting thousands of souvenirs
of little statues of liberty
of the u.s capitol and the liberty bell
which is what he used to design this
menorah
this menorah we're going to pay tribute
to
two centuries
of two cultures
this menorah
is on loan from the national museum of
american jewish history in philadelphia
just across from the liberty bell itself
and one of the honors of my career was
helping dedicate the museum in 2010
where i had a tough job following jerry
seinfeld and bent midler with the other
two speakers
thank god they didn't ask me to sing
not a joke but i was honored to join my
dear friend and museum founder ronnie
rubin who passed away this year after
dedicating that essential institution
anson passed away in 2012
and this is the second of his menorahs
to be in the white house
as we honor his work we also honor the
abiding lesson of his life
that we must be grateful for our
freedoms and we must defend those
freedoms
that is my dear friend and colleague who
worked for me for a long time my staff
before he became a prominent figure in
the congress himself
tom lantos often reminded us
in the words born out of his personal
experience escaping from hungary
and that over two thousand years of
wisdom and here's what he said he said
the veneer of civilization is paper-thin
we are its guardians
and we can never rest
well that's paper-thin
and we are its guardians
all it takes is an opening to sliver or
crack the briefest nod of acceptance of
or legitimacy
for ancient evils that have long plagued
our society
to come rushing in
and you all know it
we just saw an incident so so horribly
anti-semitic fliers being left at
people's homes in los angeles
we have to stand against resurgence of
this tide of anti-semitism and other
forms of intolerance
and hate
here at home and around the world in
that effort there is nobody more
qualified than professor deborah lipset
to our special
to
envoy
combat anti-semitism
you know when we light this menorah in
the white house when jewish families
place
menorahs in their windows we're
proclaiming liberty
we're exercising the freedom that the
maccabees sought to simply practice
their faith
and we're showing that there is still
light the demon the most fragile flame
can be sustained
in a tradition and nourish the soul of a
people
the little bit of light that little bit
of light wherever it is found can dispel
the darkness and illuminate a path
forward
and whether it's in the temple of
jerusalem or a temple of our democracy
nothing broken or profaned is beyond
repair nothing
we can always build back better or
perhaps build back brighter
so thank you all for being here as we
proclaim the light and liberty that this
is all about
and now i want to turn this over another
special guest
rabbi
lauren holst holsplat
and hulsplat excuse me you can call me
bidden
i apologize
lauren
and god bless
the united states g for ruth bader
ginsburg
that despair
despair is never ever an option never
rabbi
please come forward please
don't
give you this
gonna give it
thank you mr president
first lady dr biden
vice president harris
and
second gentleman emma
leader schumer
and let me just say
second gentlemen it is so wonderful to
see you again
rabbi alexander and i and all of addis
israel is so excited that you have been
to our synagogue and attending services
and it is our gift to have you in our
presence
wow
[Applause]
nesca
what a miracle it is to be standing here
today with all of you in the white house
blessing the light of the chanukiah i
mean
[Music]
these past 24 months have been harrowing
rabbis like myself carried shovels in
our trunks
because that was the amount of funerals
we were doing weekly we felt this
pandemic more than i can express
we have all experienced enormous loss
throughout this pandemic
and of course
it is not over
but hanukkah reminds us that light can
grow even amidst the darkest
times and we have been blessed by
awesome light
vaccines
science
leadership built on love
honesty
human dignity
and leaders that are committed to
ensuring a vibrant healthy planet for
our children and our children's children
we have to say amen to that
two thousand years ago the great sage
hillel taught us the way to light the
hanukia he won over shamai
we start with one candle and we increase
the light each night adding one more
candle a little more light night after
night
until the eighth night when we have
built a mesmerizing glow
in the dark
our change our charge is not to keep the
light only for ourselves and we know
that
we don't keep it trapped we don't keep
it privatized we don't save it for the
few
we are told rather that we should place
the hanukiah in our windows or even
outside of our doors
for the sake of pursuing nissa
so that we may publicize this miracle
and share its light
let us grow
share and be inspired by these lights
together
and let us build back better amen
it is now my honor to call up leader
schumer
to call up rabbi dr glatt
and susie stern to light the hanukkiah
and yes i will in about an hour check my
instagram i will light my menorah a
little bit later i actually have been
doing it um i missed yesterday but we're
going to get very back strongly on today
we will first light the shamish and then
we will say the blessings please say
them together with me
i share
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
the
[Music]
guys no it's not german i assume that's
a joke
[Music]
the sign language has stopped
[Music]
thank you all so much for being here and
thank you to our incredible hosts
[Applause]
i think it's over
or not it's hard to tell
[Music]
okay it is over
all right it's the fourth night of
hanukkah
and uh
it's nice to see it i i i like that i
like the rabbi mentioning science here
um
in stark contrast to what we've seen it
many of those uh circus tent churches in
the midwest uh you you love to see it uh
okay everybody we'll have more coverage
of the interrogation we looked at
earlier and everything coming up
tomorrow
um and uh i guess that's sort of it for
today thanks for joining me we are off
to the races in december and a lot of
extremely extremely powerful things
going on so we'll see everybody very
very soon
you